vous êtes à Belgorod à une trentaine de
kilomètres de la frontière avec le crâne
vue de Russie comment se déroule cette
guerre sachant que Bruno daoul le
rappelait tout à l'heure et selon les
occidentaux les Russes font face à une
existence beaucoup plus importantes
peut-être que prévu
oui alors vu de Russie on ne s'attendait
absolument
que cela fait des années qu'on vit dans
une société extrêmement militarisée
militariste on nous parle de la guerre
tous les jours on nous parle de la
grande victoire de la Russie dans la
seconde guerre mondiale et de son héros
aux yeux des Russes dans cette victoire
Joseph Staline mais il se trouve que
lorsque la guerre est arrivée ici au sud
de Belgorod dans les villages près de la
frontière dans cette ville où je me
trouve à moins de 30 km de la frontière
ukrainienne et où un nouveau front s'est
ouvert et bien les habitants n'étaient
absolument pas préparés ils n'ont pas
compris ce qui se passait ça s'est passé
avant-hier à 5h30 du matin juste après
l'annonce de Vladimir Poutine ils ont
été réveillés par les obus par les
bombardements par les hélicoptères
j'étais sur place moi aussi c'était très
impressionnant et évidemment personne
n'était préparé parce que Vladimir
Poutine n'a jamais dit d'abord qu'il
participait à cette guerre ouverte
depuis 2014 localement dans les régions
du don-basse de Denis et delougance il a
toujours affirmé que c'était une guerre
civile que c'était la population
russophone qui s'était soulevée contre
les nazis du gouvernement de Kiev
arrivait au pouvoir après la révolution
de maïdan alors avec cette annonce
totalement inattendue et bien les
habitants ont été pris de cours et c'est
un nouveau front il faut le dire qui
s'est ouvert ici plus au nord au nord
bien plus au nord que la région que
cette région du Dombas ouvre Vladimir
Poutine à affirmer envoyer son armée
nous sommes ici en phase de la deuxième
grande ville ukrainienne carquif nous
avons entendu toute la nuit des
bombardements qui se poursuivaient
encore au petit matin signe que la
bataille de carquif en plus de la
bataille de Kiev est elle aussi lancée
et pourtant ici côté rue c'est bien les
russes continuent soit de ne pas croire
à cette guerre de l'avoir lointaine bien
qu'elle est si proche je parle du
centre-ville où vous le voyez la vie la
vie ordinaire à son cours les voitures
qui circulent les magasins sont ouverts
et les Russes ils regardent cette guerre
depuis la télévision même s'il y a une
certaine anxiété puisque c'est tout près
mais la télévision Martel le message de
Vladimir Poutine comme quoi c'est
l'Ukraine qui attaque la Russie que
c'est l'Occident qui attaque la Russie
qu'il faut des nazifier l'Ukraine et
c'est un message qui à force de
propagande depuis des années et vraiment
perçu comme tel par une grande partie de
la population Elena wolochine Vladimir
Poutine a appelé l'armée ukrainienne à
cessé le combat apprendre le pouvoir à
Kiev a commencé à discuter que sait-on
de cette très éventuelle négociation
alors ce qu'on peut comprendre de de la
stratégie de Vladimir Poutine c'est
qu'il veut vraiment prendre l'Ukraine
par les armes quand on dit prendre
l'Ukraine il y a plusieurs scénarios
possibles l'hypothèse de cette ultimatum
elle m'a été évoquée dès le départ
c'est-à-dire qu'on bombarde on met des
on effectue des frappes ciblées on
réduit à néant l'armée ukrainienne
aurait dû anéant notamment sa défense
antiérienne car dès lors que l'Ukraine
ne peut plus abattre les bombardiers
russes elle n'est plus à même de se
défendre et les missiles également
puisque la taxe se fait aussi par voie
maritime avec des missiles moyennes
portées donc la stratégie c'est on met à
néant on anéantit la capacité de défense
de l'Ukraine et ensuite plusieurs
scénarios possibles le scénario le pire
c'est celui qu'on peut supposer d'après
le discours prononcé par Vladimir
Poutine sont manifestes télévisées qui a
précédé cette attaque lorsqu'il a dit
que les frontières historiques de la
Russie étaient celle de l'Empire et que
même au sein de l'Union soviétique on
aurait dû faire des régions autonomes
comme le voulait Joseph Staline et non
pas des état cependant comme l'a fait
Lénine donc dans le pire scénario il y a
ce cette hypothèse de la fédéralisation
de l'Ukraine dans Vladimir Poutine parle
depuis plusieurs années c'est à dire une
très grande fédération de Russie qui
inclurait l'Ukraine avec elle aussi des
régions fédérées ça c'est un des
scénarios possibles l'autre scénario
possible ce serait soit la
reconnaissance soit Leon autonomie soit
le rattachement à la Russie des régions
du dombasme mais non plus dans les
frontières de donia's quai de lougans où
elles ont été saisies au terme de
l'intervention de 2014 c'est-à-dire une
petite partie du territoire du Dombasle
mais une grande partie du Dombasle donc
soit rattachée soit sous une forme ou
une autre intégrée à la Russie ça c'est
un autre scénario possible et avec dans
le reste de l'Ukraine et bien un pouvoir
qui serait évidemment
soumis à Moscou un vassal de Moscou
c'est peut-être cette hypothèse qu'il
faudrait envisager davantage que celle
d'un rattachement entier de l'Ukraine
puisque il faut quand même comprendre
que et on le disait l'opinion publique
est très largement anti-rhus elle est
très largement pro-occidentale suite à
cette guerre et donc ça serait difficile
je m'imagine mal la Russie régnait sur
toute l'Ukraine en fait merci beaucoup
Elena wolochine en